hi everybody I'm here to help
inaugurate how needham into the Academy
Award honorary Oscar Hall of Fame in
case anybody who doesn't realize this
how is there's only been one other
legendary stuntman along with how to
ever receive an Oscar that entire
profession that has done so much for
cinema sometimes at the loss of their
life has only had one other person
receive a little gold man and that was
the great yakima canutt but now we have
another how Needham and as Burt Reynolds
said he is the man before he became a
director himself he pushed the
boundaries of what could be done in
stunts in action he made action living
starting from the beginning of the 60s
in particular is when he started getting
together with his stunt cronies and
figuring out how to figure out to do
fight scene so they could be better so
the action could be more exciting how
could they ki train the horse to you
know maybe if we got the horses for
months in advance we could train them to
do things that could be amazing that
they wouldn't get hurt in but it looks
spectacular and if you've ever seen
little big man a film that he was the
son gas rod some of the greatest horse
stunts ever captured on cinema and at a
certain point after being the lead
gaffer for the great and Ruger
McLaughlin for so many years he became
the second unit director on many's films
films that just pushed in the early 70s
just pushed the action to like fantastic
degrees you know Robert Aldrich let him
shoot the car chase in longest yard
Robert Aldrich just could have shot it
he was a pretty great action director
but he let how neat him shoot it same
thing with the the the great
literally white lighting has some of my
system of my favoritest car car action
ever but also in a film that we were
just talking about earlier today with
antonio margheriti
take a heart ride starring Jim Brown
I've seen a lot of antonio margaritas
work he was a cool he was a cool Italian
director but I never saw action like
that
I remember watching it the movie go what
didn't margarita start doing [ __ ] like
this alright and then I saw a second
unit director Hal Needham there you go I
got it now alright but then with he
after doing second unit work for all
that time he did Smokey and the Bandit
actually one of the most enjoyable first
directed features ever made I mean
really to this day it completely holds
up a magnificent movie of action and
comedy Burt Reynolds at his highest as
far as his persona was concerned but
also really important a true southern
movie a real southern movie not a
Hollywood southern movie a real southern
movie that understood the South in a
really really lovely way anyway it is my
honor how to honor you on this this
lovely night and this much deserved
award I've never worked with you I've
worked with a lot of people you know and
I have ripped off many shots from you
and today I say thank you very much